it's great to be joined today by chef
bar Geffen the CEO of Cody we've spoken
about Cody before it's the digital
currency built for payments Joe half
it's so great to talk to you you know
I'm so interested in this project
because at the at the sort of genesis of
cryptocurrency one of the great ideas
was it's going to be a new way for the
general public to make transactions it's
going to be used as a currency for
payments quite simply and the truth is
that because of both transaction fees in
some cases and transaction times most
crypto currencies have not really
developed in that way and is is that
sort of the general problem that you're
looking to address here yes thank you
David
actually yes and there are a few other
problems as well as we all know
cryptocurrencies and a scalability
problem meaning we're morn we're when
more people join the network it actually
becomes slower so your average
transaction per second and Bitcoin would
be like seven or twenty transactions per
second and when we compare that to the
traditional payment systems like Visa
and MasterCard you see that they go all
the way up to 65,000 transactions per
second so our cryptocurrencies are slow
the volatile price I mean I wouldn't
accept any currency as a merchant that
can drop down 20% the next day and as a
consumer I wouldn't pay with anything
that may go up 20% in the next day I
think regulation has also an important
role merchants live in their world and
have their problems dealing with their
day-to-day business operations they
won't take any currency that maybe later
suspected with anteye many long and be
money laundering and other form of
problems that may arise with the lack of
regulation and supervision and last but
not least the great promise of
cryptocurrencies the fact that it
trust the system that takes out the
middlemen while it's very good with
infrastructure cost it also comes with a
new set of problems
specifically when I pay for something
online right and I actually want the
middlemen there because if for instance
a merchant does not deliver the product
that I've ordered I I really want Visa
MasterCard of people to be there for me
to pick me up and allow me to do a
chargeback um this when you take out the
middleman with cryptocurrencies it just
never happens if you pay for something
with the Bitcoin and product is not
delivered you just made a silly human
error and press two instead of one
nobody will back you up so while we
build is super scalable it can go
Visa Mastercard scale in terms of
transactions per second it has
chargeback mechanism built in in
decentralized form it's regulated as we
have applied for a DLP license and
nothing in our network is anonymous and
it also has some price hedging in it so
merchants know that they can preserve
the value that they're getting so with
the new consensus mechanism built in
around trust we actually do something
that is really next-generation if I
referred earlier to the fact that
cryptocurrencies become a trust less
mechanism it's only in the sense that
you don't need any third party to tell
you that the balance is there and you
can pay for something and and the person
that is paying you really has the
balance you don't need a third party for
that but what cryptocurrencies doesn't
tell you and the trust that is still
needed in the system is what happens
afterwards
can I trust the person on Hank that is
not something cryptocurrency is really
answered today and with kotti we're
building a system that can actually
support this sort of decision
so if you're not only paying for
something in a trustless system you know
you can trust the other party to deliver
or you just have a chargeback mechanism
built in that system so there's a lot
there I'd like to go sort of in in short
form through some of the different
elements you mentioned to think about
how your system would sort of deal with
them so maybe hopefully some of these
will be relatively simple questions to
start with these what would be the fees
to make payments using the kodi system
okay so with cutting bottom-line these
can go all the way down to zero
absolutely zero how are we able to do
that versus traditional payment systems
it's very easy to understand we don't
need to build their infrastructures we
don't need to pay as a sort of salaries
the visa and mastercards and PayPal's of
the world pay so basically that from in
comparative that we've absolutely
nothing and we compare it comparison to
other cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin for
instance most of the costs come with
regards to proof of war or a sort of
mining that needs a lot of computation
so with kotti we've built it on a block
list system on a direct cyclic graph
data structure dad which is pretty much
block blockchain 3.0 and with that there
is very little proof of work needed very
little computation power needed so there
really there really is no need for for
high fees so a merchants using pocket
will absolutely pay very little fees now
do the transactions and we'll talk about
the token in a bit do the transactions
need to be done in your token yes well
we allow people to easily convert any
crypto that they have to coffee or fear
to coffee and vice versa because we'll
be launching our own exchange in a few
weeks this the actual transaction
happening needs to be done with the
party because it's happening on our
protocol on our own blockchain that
we've built ourselves one area I'm very
interested in is the possibility of a
sort of virtual credit or debit card
number and this is something that is
very interesting to me for two reasons
number one that the use of a virtual
credit or debit card number as opposed
to putting your actual credit or debit
card number on the Internet provides a
higher degree of security
the other issue would be that
potentially having a compliant 16 digit
or in the case of American Express I
believe it's 15 digit account number to
use online that is actually being funded
by a cryptocurrency seems to me like it
would just drastically expand the number
of places where one can directly or
indirectly pay with cryptocurrency so
talk a little bit about the virtual
debit card element yeah so we have
actually signed a partnership with a
bank in in Europe so initially won't be
launched in the US but we are hoping to
expand that that would allow you to use
a debit card pre-charged with kotti and
that will facilitate the very easy use
of Corti as a form of payment actually
merchants don't need to do a lot to to
accept coffee because first it's just
very easy to integrate with us very
seamless and and the fact that we can be
used as a simple app that emergent
installs on a phone is super easy and
integrating us to the checkout process
is very easy
we've also signed and by the way we now
saw over two thousand merchants joining
our alpha launch in August so over two
thousand merchants that apply to use
Coty and I think this is very reassuring
of how easy coffee is going to be and
and also what the demand that is there
but we've not only done that we've also
signed a partnership with protesting
comm which is a very large process or
global processor which gives us a very
integration when it comes to check out
and for the acceptance of parties so
it's a single integration that gives us
access to over 10,000 merchants so
merchants that one accept but you can
just pick a box and and in a matter of
seconds you will be able to accept
coffee through this partnership so if
the transactions can be as cheap as free
how does your organization make money
yeah well first of all it's important to
understand that you can go all the way
to zero but we allow any any nodes in
the network that run our software to
charge fees right so we'll limit there
is an upper line to how much they can
bacon its follower than anything we've
seen to date but they can actually
charge something too so that is one way
of generating coffee second way is
mediators which I guess will probably
discuss a bit later when we will speak
about how we do our charge back which is
super interesting I think they can also
be incentivized with coffee and as a
company we last but not least of course
we are operating in exchange so that's
another way of generating revenue but
but overall as we are building coffee
the team has part of it 15% of this
economy and and other than that it
completely be centralized so anybody
that wishes to go to ok we see an ml
process like we do and operate a node or
become a mediator and charge fees and
for a service and and and make money of
it what we try to do is encourage a
global usage of cote and if this if
there will be a demand for body as a
form of payment
we suspect that what we hold as as coins
will incentivize us enough upon
operating the system
not least as we're building it as a base
protocol we are fairly open to
partnerships with other companies and
other projects that really want to use a
new protocol that is super fast that has
reversibility built in it's like the
charge rate that we've built that can
actually calculate trust between parties
we're already talking with other
companies that want to use our protocol
and we're thinking of this form of
Licensing where will generate tokens or
coins when they are using it so that's
another form of revenue last thing I
want to touch on as you mentioned we as
we are getting to the end of our time is
the chargeback process how what are the
logistics of how that would work yeah
that is super interesting I think um so
first of all we already have close to a
thousand people that will be node
operators in katia that have opted in
for jury duty they they agreed to
resolve disputes between parties when
called upon these are people with high
trust force and they're going through a
process with coffee
so when dispute arises let's say I
bought something and I claimed that I
didn't I never got it the merchant says
yeah you did get it and we are now we
now need arbitration so a committee of
these mediators will be randomly picked
they don't know each other they don't
discuss the case among each other and
now they need to vote if the merchant is
right or if the consumer is right but
they don't just do that as we need to
incentivize them because we are not
paying their salaries and we want to
encourage good usage of the network they
not only vote but they actually stake
some of their coins on either side so
pool is created and when it's time to
finalize the vote and and see who's
right there's a pool there of tokens and
the side that voted with the majority
actually splits the token between
themselves so the losing side loses
these tokens the winning side wins some
tokens so this is how you create this
delegated proof of
sake of sorts and you create this
mechanism that actually over time
encourages people to judge well because
if they don't judge well and they always
vote on the wrong side they'll actually
lose tokens and eventually leave this
game but people that actually judge well
or vote with the majority and actually
win more tokens overtime very very
interesting system that's one of the
elements I found most interesting in
learning about what you're doing we've
been working speaking with Shahab our
Geffen's CEO of cody you can learn more
about both the project and the token
sale by using the links in the video
description thank you so much for
talking to us about the project thank
you David
thank you very much